so my name is Nicholas Otis I'm talking
about C++ 17 the interesting thing as
C++ 17 is just a bunch of a lot of new
little features but the real power comes
from combining them and I want to show
you that by for examples as you probably
know see purple 17 is one step further
or in the evolution of C++ we now have a
three year cycle so the three year cycle
means whatever feature is ready on time
will be delivered as in this time box
driven software project the next
delivery will be C++ 20 but she now has
feature freeze and yes so there's a big
history and some of my books cover it so
before I start I have to start with the
first slide I always have to start now I
have to talk about the way of
initialization and object initializing
an object so we had the C way the C++
way in the old C past was way the new
C++ by using curly braces so the
question is what do I use and I use
curly braces and sometimes I use in
equal sign and I just want to just have
one minute to explain why it always
works to initialize an object if you
pass no argument it detects narrowing it
is self explanatory it is works in areas
where all other or some other pieces of
initialization know that do not work for
example to initialize member in a class
you can't use parentheses and there's no
other ways to initialize an enum other
than using braces and it's a way a grits
are being initialized so don't be
surprised that I use braces in all my
examples so this is by the way not the
recommended way of the community the
community is Hydra
the worst and the way how we should
initialize an object one of the
nightmares we have now in C++ so let's
start with the first example let's talk
about if and if and trades and guards
here's an example of a function you can
question whether it's very useful but
it's more that I demo with some issues
of the C++ 17 here and the example is I
want to insert in a generic function an
element in a collection so the first
argument is a generic element and the
second one is the genic a generic
collection however I use pushback so
this essentially only works and vector
and in a deck and in a list and so let's
use it
let's for example create a vector and in
this vector of strings we want to insert
a string ok compiled fine great can I do
something more interesting here oh yeah
I want to insert an int in this
collection so what would I have to do or
what can I do well I can say well
there's a special there's an overload of
this function of this function template
saying I taken in the problem though is
that this will work nicely for an int so
for this end we now call two strings but
it will not work for a double because
for double the first function is a
better match than the second and also if
we convert it to an end we lose some
value so we need another overload to
insert a string and that might apply to
a couple of overloads we have so can we
do it better
well yes let's use an if inside the
function and that's using the zip the
question is is my past object of an
arithmetic type
and if it is we convert this arithmetic
type to a string otherwise we just try
to push it back so does it work
unfortunately not if you try to use this
function you get compile time errors
whatever you try because what you're
using here is a compile time F and
runtime F excuse me thank you and the
runtime if is only used at runtime so at
compile time all the statements have to
be valid when we instantiate this thank
you so for example if you try the first
to compile the first example you get a
small error message and in the small
error message they essentially say we
tried all a couple of things but nothing
worked so what's in your first new
feature here a compile time F with this
compile time if you can say ok let's
insert that's called pushback or with
two string if it's an arithmetic type
and otherwise use pushback fine trust
problem soft since the paths are
seventeen you can write the expression
saying a type trait saying is this
arithmetic then then the type and then
colon colon value a little bit shorter
to say is there at mythic underscore V
okay let's improve this a little bit and
let's use mutexes because we have a
multi-threaded environment so let's do
it by the vector is locked okay
so we might have a mutex introduce mutex
where we get access to the vector and
then we might use a la carte to say
before we try all these insertions let's
lock it so the next thing we can do
better in C++ 17 so we no longer have to
specify once again the type of the new
tax when we declare the locker that's
called class template argument deduction
and it means that even in class
templates you can now deduce the type of
template parameters in this case it's a
type of the mutex used so that you can
just write what you want okay however it
might happen it might be that we have
other things to do in inside a string so
the piece of code you see in insert a
string is only some piece of code and we
might do something in from then we might
be do something behind inserting the
element and then it's not it the best
strategy to use mutex that locks a
vector for the whole time so let's lock
the mutex inside the function so we
might extend the API of this insert a
string function and say okay let's add
an additional argument which is the
mutex to lock so that the collar can
pass a mutex for the vector and then
inside the function just for the if
statement during either pushing back the
element converted to string or the other
push back let's then use the lock up so
that it's the vectors only look at this
little piece of moment at this protected
reel so don't forget to put a braces
here because we want to make sure that
right after the pushback because the
lifetime of the lock guard has entered
the mutex is unlocked can we do it
better now with c++ 17 yes we can we can
use and if constructs a compile time if
you just saw so we can say we have a
compile time F but this if looks
different than the one before
look at that it has a semicolon in the
middle and this is a new way of that is
supported now in C++ 17
if with initialization we can also add
an initialization to switch now for
those who ask me can you also have an
initialization and wire now yes we have
that for years it's called fall and yeah
so we have that now and it even works
with at compile time and now this is
tricky look at that at compile time we
evaluate the condition but the
initialization is done at compile at run
time that's okay that's allowed this is
a compile time is in both cases in
design and the elds case we have a run
time initialization of the Lockhart but
we decided compile time whether we
compile these then or the else case
that's support so that's in UF with
initialization we worry a little bit
first of all can we improve that even
better yes there might be an issue that
we might not need a lot mutex or that we
might multiple need multiple new Texas
for whatever reason so we have a new
very attic lock out now and it is called
scope lock and what you can now even
improve here you can say let's pass an
arbitrary number of mutexes to this
function that might be lock why we call
pushback so you might still pass one
mutex but you might also pass two
mutexes note that these mutexes might
have different types because this is a
very attic template oh you might and by
the way if we have multiple mutexes here
then the scope lock that locks mutexes
uses the standard function STD lock
which has a deadlock avoidance mechanism
so that we try to avoid deadlocks here
only here not in general you can still
create that locks yourself and so that
that we that we are has better safety
here in in our code
and you can pass no mutex at all and
that's also supported by a scope block
if there is no mutex passed then it will
not lock anything so this code is
essentially now generic in a way that we
might even not lock a mutex at all and
that gives us some flexibility you might
be happy about in your code okay so look
at this the next step look at that the
initialization you might say we can
improve the initialization of the scope
block here in the if constructs fix
expression that's LG LG is initialized
by a couple of mutexes and that performs
the lock for all the past mutexes so do
I need the name of the Lord God Bo no in
from a Paramus perceptive I don't need
the name so let's improve this version
and remove the name so let's create a
temporary lock here well or multiple
temporary locks on depending on how much
mutexes we passed unfortunately this is
not an improvement because what we have
done here you have created a temporary
block object Alaka the lifetime of this
locked object is not until the end of
the control structure its until you find
the semicolon so even before the
condition this lock will be unlocked
again so and there's no compile time
error on that will it will just not lock
and probably at runtime in production
create some interesting issues so don't
do that that's a fatal runtime error
please give it a name and that's it
that's more or less every combination I
I want to introduce here so you have
seen here I think five or six different
new features just in this one line in
the if context for line so we're using a
compiler
if you are using a knife with an
initialization you are using a scope
lock you are using its arithmetic we as
a shortcut and you're using class
template argument to the action because
you don't have to specify the type of
the mutexes when you declare that the
class template object scope block so
that's nice that's a little improvement
and by the way yes C++ would not be in
C++ it was a new feature we wouldn't
introduce new traps and that's all here
by the way this is not a new trap if you
do the same in a for loop you would run
into the same problem so if you use the
initialization in the follow
having no name for the lock you haven't
locked via mutexes during the follow so
don't do that okay um there are other
traps so we have to talk about so class
template argument deduction is a little
bit funny it can be used very well like
in the example of these locks and la
carte but beware if initialization
becomes complicated and follows
complicated rules so yes if you declare
a vector of yeah you don't say what it
is and you pass some curly braces here
saying this vector is initialized by 2
inch class argument deduction class
template argument deduction will deduce
that this is a vector of int and that
also works for one element if you don't
use curly braces here then the
initializer list constructor is not used
so we will still deduce a vector of int
but the int has 8 elements of the value
15 and if you have last value not passed
with curly braces this will not compile
because
overload resolution will find the
constructor that is marked with the
error now and in this constructor from
this constructor oh no the one before
and the one before the error
Eero constructor that cannot be used to
the use type t so this will not compile
um but you can initialize you can try to
initialize eight elements of the string
literal so that's this work if anything
is here it works when we consider
deduction so we will deduce the type of
T we will find out that the type of an
element is yeah what is the type of this
empty string little it's a constant
array it's an area of constant
characters and there it has a size of 1
because we only have the null terminator
here and now it's important that the
constructor takes this argument by
reference and because it takes it by
reference it does not decay so this type
has not decayed to become a contra
pointer it has a type as I just said so
type T is deduced to be a charity uh-oh
the concerts wrong here by the way
because the concerts in front of the T
anyway so T is deduce to be just an an
array of one character and that's
unfortunately will be deduced but it
will not compile because you can't
instantiate a vector with an array
that's it ok other examples here I skip
that it's good enough there are more
problems to show but we already run out
of time to demo all the eggs of the
problems next problem
every problem has 15 minutes roughly
every example did I say problem no
feature cool feature okay next example
very Eric templates let's use very Eric
templates variadic templates were
introduced in C++ 11 so that you could
write functions like this you can say I
have a print function on the bottom here
and the print version takes one argument
or an arbitrary number of additional
arguments and so we can pass
arguments the first argument is always
printed and the next one is passed to
recursively be passed to print again to
print it out and that we recursively
instantiate so at the end we essentially
have to compile or create assembler code
for printing out all the arguments we
passed to print that's nothing new in
C++ seventeen-year but we have a problem
here in C++
and the problem is recursive
instantiation because of instantiation
takes a lot of resources and the
compiler takes time and is something we
try to avoid so can we do it better yes
we have something new out first of all
the first question might be for the end
criterion which is here an empty print
can be used around time if no that's not
allowed but you can use the compile time
if you find the compile time if here to
end this recursion so that you don't
have to need in print have an empty
printf at the end however can we do it
better than this then recursively
instantiating templates plus a function
templates and yes we have a new feature
called a fold expression you can say if
I have a gender as if I have a very
attic number of arguments or what we
call a parameter pack this you can say
that we apply a certain operator to all
of the arguments like here saying all of
the arguments should be combined with
the operator plus and that means you
can't pass a different number of
arguments of different types as long as
pluses allowed to call this will compile
and concatenate or add all the values
here the problem here is if you don't
pass no argument then we have no value
here but for that reason you can say I
have an initial value like zero so that
even works then for the case that we
don't have any value in the parameter
pack good so that new feature can be
applied to our print function and we can
we replace a whole recursive
instantiation by just this saying okay
this is trend all for all the arguments
we print them out to see out that's it
the syntax is parentheses dot out dot
and in the middle on the left way of the
initialization on the right of parameter
Peck and then you have to pass which
operation to a bush operator to call it
has to be the same on both sides
so we essentially compile and say let's
print out all the values we don't
recursively instantiate that that
complies a lot faster way faster than
before and yeah we have our output oh
wait a minute there's a space meeting
missing between these arguments so how
can we fix the space well we can easily
extend this expression you can say at
the end of this there should still be a
newline that's fine but you can't put
extend the syntax or change the syntax
of this operation
it needs a syntax braces initializer two
times the operator daughter dot in the
middle and I'm going to write the
parameter pack well but the parameter
pair can be an expression so you can say
something like this let's print out all
the arguments and for the arguments but
I call a helper function that prints out
a space before the argument the next
argument well and we don't want to do
that for the first argument of course
so we now introduce the special handling
saying the first argument if it comes is
printed out and for all remaining
arguments we print them also all by
calling a helper function space before
which prints out the space returns our
argument and then we print out the
argument okay don't take a picture of
this we are not done
so yes this works because this
effectively compiles something like this
we print out the first argument and we
print out then for the further argument
that we called space before but wait a
minute there's an issue if you that the
yellow box here if you would have
implemented that just as a piece of code
in C++ 11 or 14 you have two different
possible outputs here there is you might
either print hi space 7.5 space well or
you might have the output hi tube spaces
7.5 world without of space in between
because we have no guaranteed evaluation
order here in regarding the effect when
an upper rent here is evaluated so the
evaluation of space before printing out
the space might happen for both
arguments before we start actually to
print out the rest so the R as the
results of what was printed out what was
returned by space before however this is
fixed with C++ 17 yeah we have for this
reason to make this compile not for this
example but there are other example we
have introduced now some constraints on
the operators we have already so you see
in red here so the changes we made we
have now a guaranteed evaluation order
for some operators some operators here
like dot and arrow from left to right
function calls no guarantee that the
left side of the function so the name of
the function is evaluated before its
arguments the argument order is still
undefined and then we have evaluation or
are also for the output operator and
input operator which we just use and
also for the assignment operator we
didn't define an evaluation arrow for
audio other operators that there was a
big fight and
for those who like fast compilers they
said oh that's too much and we because
we pay a price not using the ideal way
to evaluate expressions so that means
this is now guaranteed to work by the
way note that we still don't have a
guaranteed evaluation order in function
arguments so if you pass them as
arguments to a function call you might
still get two spaces in ahead okay
that's it let's use it however can we
make it better
yes we can but we have to solve a
problem and the problem is we are you
can as you just saw use expressions to
parameter pecks and then this expression
is is used for all the arguments so
besides saying if I take an arbitrary
number of arguments I pass them all to
fool you can say something works rather
like this you can say I passed to foo a
teacher for each argument added to
itself as a comma-separated list that's
not nothing new in C++ 17 that's already
supported in C++ 11 however what a lot
of people tried out this let's call foo
for each argument and the problem is
this does not compile and can we do it
now in C++ 17 yes you can this is a way
to do it you say you use a fault
expression and you use it with a comma
operator so you create a sequence of
comma operator calls to call for each
argument to call foo and that's the way
you can do it now please note that this
strange feature that we can overload the
collaborator might create trouble so
each time you call a function where you
don't know whether what it returns you
should cast it to avoid it by the way I
learned in the meantime there
also workaround before si plus by 17 it
looked like this so you could take the
guaranteed evaluation opener of
initializing an initializer list to
extend that's an initialization for a
list to call all the few arguments you
need it at the comma there because at
the end you had to initialize a
initialize and initialize a list of Ind
just to throw it away so that was a
workaround that did work even in C++ 11
I think the new way is a little bit more
readable than before and of course the
new way we can use this move semantics
then it looks like this so what does it
mean in our example print all the
arguments but have spaces between them
use a comma operator use a lambda that
prints out a space and the argument and
do that good can we do it better
yes here we have a space we have between
the arguments we want to be more
flexible here so let's introduce a new
template argument saying let's have a
character here and the default values of
space so we can call print by default
having a space between the between the
arguments but we can change this and now
a new feature is called Auto here so you
can have different types here we have
now a new feature saying that the
template and non type template argument
can be declared without all which means
that you can decide as a color what is
printed beside this so you could now
pass to print as a template parameter 42
so between each argument there would be
written 42 which might not be very
useful here but we have another feature
which is you can now have local strings
defined with no linkage and pass them
directly to a template and that way you
can say let's
all the arguments with even a string
literal in between and that works now we
are still waiting for that you can
directly pass in the template argument
the string literal that will probably
come as far as I know in C++ 20 okay
and for those who hate semicolons or
having something in two statements
instead of one you can do it in one
statement define the lambda and use it
in the Foley expression to call apply
this lambda to all the arguments in
print okay that's one comment here we
use this feature also in the standard
for argumented action for example we
have what we call so-called a deduction
guide specifying if you have an area of
an arbitrary number of values not
specifying the type of the elements we
did use that's a new feature also we
have we did use that all the elements in
the array have the type of the first
argument so we have a special name for
the first argument and then we also
deduce that we have nine elements
because it's a number of further
arguments plus the first argument
however to avoid that we have used this
feature when we initialize with
different data types we have here say we
we disable this deduction guide so we
disable this automatic deduction if all
the elements don't have the same value
and what we use here is a fold
expression saying well for all the
template arguments we have to check
whether all the later arguments have the
same type as a first argument and if
it's not the case we disable this
deduction okay time is good third
example
let's use a vector of strings and let's
initialize a vector of strings with some
IDs well with some strings where we have
prefix either being a lowercase ID or
capital case ID and then a value and
integral value converted to a string so
we get a sequence of values like you see
here on the right in the bubble let's
sort that so that's fine works fine you
will get a result that's not the point
let's sort them ignoring the first two
characters because we want to ignore the
prefix which would give different
results and this takes significant time
here you will see why
or you will see how it takes this
significant type we would say let's use
a substring of the string the problem is
the substring function for string
creates a new temporary string and even
if you have short string optimisation so
that no heap memory is involved that is
that is complicated that takes too much
time and effort so that we more than
double the speed of this sorting by just
ignoring the first two characters so can
we improve that yes we have a new beast
called string view spring view creates
just the view to the spring and this
view does not create a new string
because it does only refer to the
characters of the underlying string and
if we then in this view take a substring
we make it faster because we don't
create a new string we only reduce of
view to the string so let's see and you
see that we roughly have around the the
time the performance we had in the
original sort not dealing with sub
strings I have to say something about
string view here before we continue with
this example
let's have a break and go to string you
this is how string U is working if you
have some value in your system a spring
at all you can create a string which
means the string creates a copy of the
value because it owns the whole value
it's a value type or you can now have a
string view saying I don't own the value
I only refer to it which is fast but
dangerous
so it's string view is like a raw
pointer if you see the world the word
underscore view in a program you have to
get scary
that's a smell that's a smell like using
pointers you run into the same danger
yes once for your life learn that please
and however they are safe use it risk
but you have to be very careful with
that
you can even implicitly create a string
view from a spring please note that the
thing on the top a spring me from a
spring lateral is safe because as this
string literal has a lifetime for the
whole program you will never refer to
something that is not owned by you by
the spring due to the string depends on
the lifetime of the string you refer to
and that's a some danger that you make
mistakes
here's a nice piece of code that
demonstrates how easily you can fall
into traps now let's create a string
view referring to the string little high
and then somebody in your team in your
project has written these three lines of
code which say let's add a string due to
its to another string view well the guy
who wrote this function made everything
right don't return a string view here
that would be wrong because we have now
created a new string that has to refer
to new memory we create a string an sed
string so we convert the two string
views to a string concatenate them and
return the string a temporary object
that is a string and
let's find so far now
the third guy in your project has
written a cool temptation template let's
add two elements of a type and return
the Sun yeah this looks safe add two
inch you get an int add two strengths
you get a string what's the problem so
the problem is let's use this template
for my string view and so my string
Mutai is passed twice to this function
sum which calls the plus operator the
plus operator will create a temporary
string and the temporary string is the
outcome of the expression X plus y and
the template and return it to the caller
however the return type is T and T is a
type we passed in and the type we passed
in was a string view so what do we
return we return a string view to this
temporary string and then the temporary
string is destroyed so that's what we
return that's not fine
if you use it if you are lucky you get a
quorum so who made a mistake here well
beside you B can argue whether an
implicit type conversion from string to
string three is a good thing who made a
mistake here it's clearly it's clearly
the guy in the middle because he made an
assumption which was wrong the
assumption was that if you concatenate
two objects of type T the outcome is a T
and that assumption is wrong and
dangerous so please don't make it that's
a compiler find out about the real it'll
try this and this is also one of my
slides I always demonstrate when I
explain to people why it's so important
to use outer end function templates it's
correct maybe not that readable but it's
right and that's more important and even
if inside you you will have a temporary
object for the some use out of there
so Auto is your friend and templates
even as a return type
so don't if you have a star guy to void
out all it's wrong if you implement
templates good by the way we have we
know this problem we are getting a lot
more problems like this in the standard
because we introduce a lot more types
now that have no value semantics that
have reference semantics like string
view span if you read the suffix
underscore span and see plus 20 that's a
stain juris as underscore view so
they're all dangerous so and we have a
problem now because we will run and we
will run into these problems we have
seen that already people fall falling
into this trap so we thought about how
to solve that the only way we can solve
that is that we in an interface of a
function we can express lifetime
dependencies so in the function that
would convert a string to a string wheel
we have to specify that the resulting
string you the the lifetime of that
depends on the lifetime of the string
you pass there and when we can do that
and I hope we soon can do that in C++
then we can detect this problem at
compile time not using valgrind
ourselves at compile time we could
detect this problem well there are
different proposals to build that path
one proposal both by halves at another
bath by which that smooth and me have
Sarah's team implemented already an
experimental solution of this if you
haven't heard about that please look at
it
let's have Sarah's lifetime profile this
is a tool that implements the way that
you can specify lifetime dependencies in
function calls and that way you can
detect the problem I just demoed to you
here on the left there's a god bold
implementation with this
extension and we see exactly what the
problem is if we turn on - W lifetime so
you get the warning about what I just
explained to you and I think this is a
very very important tool for your
quality gates before you deliver
software because it will be very cheap
because you don't need to complete test
coverage with well grind and run time
it's a compile time feature that detects
several bugs in your program in your
programming code good so coming back to
our example we learned string U is your
friend if you use it wisely and that's
fine here because we only create a
temporary string view for the strings we
sought and all the strings exist until
the end of the sort algorithm so that's
fine here can we improve this even
better
yes we can use parallel algorithms so we
have a new extension now in C++
everything team that says you can
prioritize algorithms so this is
essentially calling the sequential model
but we can now switch to parallel
execution of this sort and now look at
the numbers which are not representative
which are not precise it's on my laptop
my numbers having run it at several
times but you see there is significant
speed-up in this even in this small
example only having I don't know 1
million elements you see that you are
even better than the initial version by
a factor of 2.5 better than the initial
sort without the substring feature so
yeah we have something the boss the bad
thing is that when you can't specify how
many threads are used and which
constraints are there it all depends on
the implementers of this library things
like that will come later and later C++
standards it's just it's there so the
only way to validate whether it's worth
it to power
Isis or not measure on the platform you
use with the typical scenario you have
when I learned about parallel algorithm
I raised one question I said why the
hell do we have a parallel partial sum
function now because here's the partial
Fang it's a partial sum algorithm it
says let's compute for sequence of
values all the partial sums so the first
result is 3 the next is 3 plus 1 the
next is 3 plus 1 plus 7 etc that way we
convert relative values for example to
absolute values or so which is pretty
common to need because we might try to
find a threshold where we where the bar
was too high when we had added different
values so that's an algorithm that's
widely often used and we have a parallel
version of it in C++ 17 that's a new it
has a new name because we guarantee
evaluation from left to right before
partial sum which would rule out
parallelization at all but I would say
we also rule out parallelization because
we have to start from left to right
because we have to start with the first
and second we need all these results but
what I learned is that prioritization is
nice because sometimes you can invent
better algorithms than before and
there's a way to parallelize this I'll
show you how if you have this sequence I
extended the sequence by another 8
elements and the way you parallel eyes
to compute all the partial sums is not
to start with the first partial sum then
the second etc you do the following you
sum up all the all the intermediate sums
first of the of all two elements then of
all four elements and of all eight
elements etc so you compute a binary
tree of all the sums and then you go
down and use this information to compute
the final values
and as you see in all the steps here
everywhere where we use here on the same
level
multiple computations they all can be
computed in prowl so we have to change
the algorithm to come from 1/8 naive
implementation to something interesting
but the result is that the computing of
a partial sum can be 10 times faster if
you have I don't know a CPU with 30 Kos
or so and we see that in practice and so
that's that I found interesting so
there's more than just a naive thinking
of this can't be parallelized
so we can benefit from this knowledge
and please note we don't need any
additional memory here we don't have to
compute allocate memory to get the
result we just we use the memory we have
ok last example unions polymorphism
overloading lambdas that's one of my
favorite and it solves the problem
forming problem if we have polymorphism
the classical way we would implement
this with inheritance saying I have a
base class geometric objects and to
concrete class circle inline so let's
create the an object and the problem is
to have polymorphism you need a vector
of pointers and because it's pointers
you need you because otherwise after the
creation of the vector the element might
be destroyed but you still use the
pointer so you come up with something
like this you might initialize the
figure of different geometric objects
calling new everywhere and then push it
back return it and then you use it and
then at the end don't forget before you
clean remove all the elements and the
vector that you call delete because
otherwise you have a memory leak and yes
you can improve that a little bit by
using shared pointers and unique
pointers which have their own problems
so you can replace this problem by
another problem which might be less but
there are significant problems shared
pointer have a performance problem and
the unique point
have some restrictions regarding what
you can do for example you can't do a
down cast dynamic cast on a unique
pointer so it's an alternative and the
alternative surprisingly comes with C++
17 with a new data type and the new data
type is called variant and this is a
kind of a new type for Union so a
variant is I am also I am either and in
all long all string now you might say
wait a minute wait a minute we have a
union already and C and C++ with a
keyboard Union so what's a cool thing
here the cool thing here is this Union
knows what it holds and it has a
slightly improved API so instead of
saying let's set the value as an end or
as a long you just say assign a string
assign 40 to assign along and
automatically the assignment will find
the best match here and use this value
and the Union and the variant then knows
what it holds so if you ask now the
variant what are you holding it will
give you the index of this information
and say I'm holding a spring or I'm
holding a long etc and by the way you
see that even implicit type conversions
are possible you assign a string literal
and the best match for spring level is
STDs ring so this is used and then if
you know that you can access a value by
different ways one is calling get and if
you then use the wrong index on invalid
index you either get a runtime or
compile time error that's it so how can
this help us our example our fourth
example saying let's use polymorphism
well we have a variant here we can say
in my vector I have elements that are
either a circle all lines that's all
what we say so we introduce a helper
type called I'm either a circle or line
and I use that as the element type of a
vector
the interesting thing is a variant has
value semantics so if you put it in a
vector the vector creates a copy if you
put in a line the vector creates a copy
of the line if you put in a variant that
as a circle it will create a copy of the
circle so you don't run into the
problems of lifetime issues because you
use references or pointers and that also
means you don't have to deal with new
and delete you just create the things on
the stack push them into the vector and
that's it and return the vector and then
later on you use it and now the problem
is how can we bring polymorphism into
this saying while I'm iterating over all
the geometric objects I have either to
call draw for an object or draw for line
so essentially something the kind of
code you have to write is if the variant
holds the circle call draw of a circle
if the variant holds a line called row
of a line that kind of thing and you
should have a good performance you
should not have it in if-else Shane you
had should have smarter things to do
that like in a virtual function table
and here's a way you do that it's a
called visit so with with it you can say
hey my dear variant for each and every
value if you take the value please use
this function or you can pass a function
object with multiple functions there and
call this code and this is a generic
lambda so this is a function template
that is instantiated for all the types
we have so this generic lambda will be
complied once for circle once for line
and both will be available in this
visitor at compile time
this visit function checks that all the
instance ages are valid so that each
type has a draw function and then the
code will be generated that depending on
the index of the alternative you jump to
the right function in sensation of this
lambda and this instantiation was then
called draw that's it that's a local
virtual function table generated by
visit for you
and that's it that way you have your
polymorphic solutions no reason to worry
about memory leaks everything is on the
stack there's no need for pointers no
new delete and note that there's another
benefit all the elements in the vector
are now located next to each other so
regarding caching good caching this
works better than before
because the alternative using pointers
means we have pointers which might refer
to different locations in your program
so that you have two that the likely
that is more probable that you get cache
page faults and have to wait for getting
the corresponding data into your CPU and
wait a minute we are not using the base
term we are not using polymorphous and
using rato so forget it
you can still have a base class if you
have some common information but you
don't need the base class as an
interface that is used in your
implementation so you can just have a
type called circle a type called
line and that's it the third alternative
here could be a string and a CD string
and it would also work as long as the
string has the s draw we call a common
API okay two questions usually come here
first of all do we have something how do
we do a Down cast here so let's assume
circle has a center a special function
called get center so normally in
polymorphism we use dynamic casts in
SharePoint us we use dynamic pointer
cast and in unique pointers we have to
convert the unique pointer to a row
pointer and called dynamic cast and so
here we have now a different approach
the approach is call a function called
get is get if is the dynamic cast of a
variant it says let's take the address
of this variant because we don't have
pointers and then let's try to convert
this to a circle pointer if this works
we are fine
and then we can get a pointer a valid
point to address otherwise we get the
null pointer so we use the new if within
a civilization to double check whether
we have a pointer and if we have a point
that we use it to call gate Center
that's it
and that's very fast that's usually
faster I measured that then the
polymorphic approach in using a
visitor's for example here's by the way
another way to do that you could come up
with by what you just saw you could
inside the lambda have a compile time if
expression double checking when you
currently have the implementation that
you're Auto type is in fact a circle
type which means that your object is a
con circle reference
don't forget constant reference there
then you can here directly do something
this is decided at compile time whether
this piece of code printing out get
center should be compiled or not
depending on which in sensation of this
lambda is used so there's another
interesting way over to overload this
out to implement downcast this is this
you can overload lambdas and this
overload of lambdas even works is one of
the lambdas generic and the other is a
circle we might run into some issues
because we have the best problem of the
best match when we have overload
resolutions so be very careful if you do
that for example that all the
declarations have all cons and all
reference because otherwise interesting
surprises might happen but you can do it
and you can say for all the elements in
normal elements I call draw but for
circles I call center and that way you
could say if my variant holds an STD
string I do something totally different
now the question is what is what the
hell is this overload well this is a
combination of a couple of new C++ 17
features it's it's not standardized it's
something you have to implement but you
can easy implement and this is the way
it is implemented it's essentially four
lines of code
what you say here is I have here a data
structure overload that is derived from
a couple of factors and these factors
are coming from argument deduction in
the last line you say whatever you pass
as a template as an argument to this
overload function please deduce that you
take the type of these things you pass
as an argument as template parameters so
that says and that essentially we are
saying I have I passed two lambdas these
two lambdas are passed to the overload
constructor this overload constructor
says oh yeah so these are my two
template parameters and the two template
parameters are my base types so we
derive from all types of all lambdas we
have here in this overload without
specifying their types and then you have
to because each overload implements
operator perón which means which is a
problem if you derive from multiple
classes the same operator it is
invalidated it's not inherited but you
can use a using declaration to still
make it available and we do that and
this is a very attic using declaration
which is also something new and C++ 17
so by having all these features you
essentially have the effect you just saw
okay
we're thinking about to standardizing it
but we're also thinking there are some
things where this doesn't work perfectly
so we are also thinking whether
overloading of a lambda shouldn't be a
language feature so that that's one
reason why this will not come and C++ 20
so this is using SD variant and by the
way what is this also using it's what
you initialize here is an aggregate
that's not a class that's an aggregate
aggregates in C++ can now have base
classes and that feature is used here
and we have deduction guides and we have
very added using all these features are
used to have this
and I have to say that he only curly
braces work
don't use parentheses here because
that's the initialization of an
aggregate but I told you already you
should always use phrases for
initialization and you're fine you don't
worry about very strange compiler errors
messages if you use parents here that's
it so we have seen several several new
features of C++ 17 and they examples in
for examples each and every example used
combined at the end several features of
what were introduced all each and every
feature as well is very very small to
some extent but together we create an
interesting amount of power in C++ 17
and that's my message combining these
features is the key especially that
makes C++ 70 much more powerful than we
thought initially just reading a list of
the features and yes we introduced new
traps and that's a good reason you buy
my book
haha about C++ 17 to read all about
about all traps I at least know about
yet it is now being published close in
three weeks it will be published at
Amazon as a printing ROG now the
electronic version was already available
for two years because it was updated
regularly for free for those who bought
it so you might be interested to see
these and other details there and that's
the end of my talk thankee thank you
very much for your attention
[Applause]